en esta ocasión tenemos dos expresiones
en la primera estamos multiplicando dos
expresiones racionales y aquí abajo
estamos dividiendo dos expresiones
racionales una entre la otra y lo que te
invito a hacer es pausar el vídeo y ver
en qué se convierten estas expresiones
cuando las multiplique eso cuando las
divididas no lo sé a lo mejor tendrás
que simplificar un poco todo esto y
también quiero que pienses que
restricciones le tienes que poner a los
valores de x para que tu expresión
resultante sea algebraica mente
equivalente a tu expresión original así
que pausa el vídeo ok resolvamos esto
juntos para que veas a lo que me refiero
así que veamos la primera que nos va a
quedar déjame ver nos va a quedar lo
siguiente 6x cúbica por 2 en el
numerador 6x kubica x
y esto en el numerador y en el
denominador nos va a quedar 5 por 3x de
lujo y bueno podemos simplificar un poco
esto si dividimos todo entre x déjame
ver si dividimos todo entre x entonces
este se va y me va a quedar 1 éste se va
y me va a quedar x cuadrada muy bien y
también podemos dividir todo entre 3 si
dividimos todo entre 3 este se va y
también me queda 1 y bueno 6 entre 3 lo
podemos dividir y me queda 2 así que en
la parte de arriba en el denominador voy
a obtener 2x cuadrada por 2 lo cual es
4x cuadrada y en la parte de abajo me va
a quedar 5 por 1 por 1 lo cual es 5
recuerda que estos se están
multiplicando y estos también se están
multiplicando muy bien entonces mi
respuesta es 4 x cuadrada entre 5 que
por cierto también
podemos escribir como cuatro quintos
cuatro quintos de equis cuadrada muy
bien ahora imagínate no sé que alguien
está en la calle y te pregunta para qué
valores está definida esta expresión que
tengo aquí cuatro quintos de equis
cuadrada
bueno pues tú vas a contestar yo puedo
poner cualquier equis aquí en por
ejemplo puedo poner el valor de x igual
a cero porque bueno pero al cuadrado es
cero por cuatro quintos esto me quedaría
cero y puedo poner cualquier valor que
se me ocurra justo en esta expresión
ahora bien
imagínate que esa misma persona te
pregunta cómo se debe restringir esta
expresión que tengo aquí para que sea
algebraica mente equivalente a la
primera expresión a la expresión con la
que empezamos bueno necesitarías decir
que la primera expresión no está
definida para todas las x por ejemplo si
x fuera igual a 0 entonces justo aquí
estaríamos dividiendo entre 0 lo que
ya que esta expresión no estuviera
definida por lo que explícitamente
podemos decir que x no puede ser igual a
entonces si quieres que cuatro quintos
de x cuadrada se algebraica mente
equivalente a esta expresión que tengo
aquí entonces tendrías que poner la
misma condición x no puede ser 0 x no
puede ser 0 otra manera de pensarlo es
la siguiente déjame subir un poco la
pantalla
imagínate que ahora quieres tomarte lo
siguiente no sé vamos a suponer que tú
defines una función que se llama fx y
esta función
fx es igual a 6x cúbica entre 5 y esto a
su vez multiplica a 2 entre 3 x y
alguien te dice cuánto vale
efe de cero bueno pues tú puedes decir
que f de 0 no está definido para esta
función déjame ponerlo así
efe de 0
indefinido pero bueno a lo mejor te
preguntas si puedes simplificar esto un
poco para obtener la misma función y
estamos viendo que esto se puede
simplificar a lo siguiente vas a llegar
a que fx va a ser de la forma déjame
ponerlo así cuatro quintos de x cuadrada
cuatro quintos de x cuadrada pero ten
cuidado porque si estás definiendo aquí
esta función en el valor de cero vas a
obtener un valor f de 0 en esta función
es lo mismo que 0 y nosotros no queremos
eso queremos que f de 0 sea indefinido
lo que hace que esta función sea una
función distinta a la que teníamos en un
principio en esta manera como están
escritas estas dos funciones son
funciones distintas entonces para
aclarar que estas dos funciones son
equivalentes entre sí son algebraica
mente equivalentes entre sí entonces
tenemos que poner la restricción de que
x no puede ser cero
x no puede ser 0 y ahora si estas dos
funciones son equivalentes ya que si te
preguntan ahora por el valor de f de 0
en esta función f de 0 en esta función
bueno pues vas a decir que x no puede
ser igual a 0 entonces en este caso
efe de 0 es indefinido y sabes si x
fuera cualquier cosa distinta esto
tendría un valor pero no está definida
para el 0 y ahora si puedes afirmar que
estas dos funciones son funciones
equivalentes perfecto y ahora vamos a
pensar justo en esta división que
tenemos aquí pero vamos a pensarla de
una manera parecida a lo que pasó acá
arriba tenemos ahora esta división de
aquí y bueno inmediatamente cuando ves
esto te puedes preguntar cuál es la
restricción aquí la restricción en este
caso es que x no puede ser igual a 0 no
puede ser igual a 0 porque cuando tú
pones el valor de 0 justo aquí estás
dividiendo entre 0 entonces en esta
expresión de aquí
hemos decir explícitamente que x no
puede tomar el valor de 0
independientemente de que nos dé de
expresión equivalente después de
simplificar un poco esta expresión sea
lo que sea que obtengamos aquí para que
el resultado sea algebraica mente
equivalente a la expresión original
entonces tenemos que dar la misma
restricción bueno pues vamos a
trabajarlo vamos a hacer esta división y
bueno dividir 2 x a la cuarta entre 7
entre 5 x la cuarta entre 4 es
exactamente lo mismo
déjame ponerlo con este color que
tomarme 2 x a la cuarta entre 7 ya esto
multiplicarlo lo voy a hacer con este
color ya esto multiplicarlo por el
recíproco de este por 4 entre 5 x a la
cuarta potencia y bueno así va a ser
mucho más fácil resolverlo porque esto
aquí va a ser igual esto va a ser igual
8x a la cuarta potencia 2x a la cuarta
por 4 es 8x a la cuarta entre 7 por 5 es
35 35 x a la cuarta potencia muy bien y
si ahora queremos simplificar un poco
esta expresión podemos dividir tanto
arriba como abajo entre x a la cuarta y
simple y sencillamente me voy a quedar
con 8 entre 35 y 8 entre 35 y una vez
más aquí estás viendo 8 sobre 35 y esto
va a estar definido para cualquier x
de hecho x ni siquiera está involucrada
en esa expresión pero ojo si queremos
que esta expresión sea algebraica mente
equivalente a la expresión con la que
empezamos entonces tenemos que dar la
misma restricción x no puede ser igual
y bueno sabes decir que x no puede ser
igual a 0 en una expresión donde x no
está involucrada parece que no tienen
nada de sentido pero si lo pensamos en
términos de una función que vamos a
construir ahorita no sé se me ocurre
pensar en la función g g de x y
definimos ag de x como todo esto que
tenemos aquí y bueno por otra parte
simplificamos justo esto y llegamos a kg
de x es igual a 8 entre 35 ahora observa
en esta primera expresión de x igual a
2x a la cuarta sobre 7 entre 5 x a la
cuarta sobre 4
bueno pues 70 en esta expresión es
indefinido no está definido pero si
dices aquí gdx igual a 8 sobre 35 y
ahora piensas en que de 0 bueno pues si
está definido que de 0 es igual a 8
sobre 35 lo que haría que esta función
de aquí fuera una función distinta a la
función original entonces para hacer
estas expresiones algebraica mente
equivale
es lo que tenemos que hacer es lo
siguiente podemos definir la función de
x de la siguiente manera podemos decir
que la función g de x es la función que
toma el valor del 8 sobre 35 para x
distinta de 0 para x distinta de 0 y es
indefinida para x igual a 0 para x igual
a 0 o bueno si quieres puedes prescindir
del último renglón y quedarte solamente
con la parte de arriba y esto
literalmente haría indefinido el valor
de x igual a 0 y ahora ya está sabemos
que estas dos expresiones que tengo aquí
esta expresión de aquí
y mi expresión original son algebraica
mente equivalentes a pesar de que ya la
hallamos simplificado